this video is brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespaces the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and run your
business check out squarespace through the link
in the description below more about them in a bit
mad bad and dangerous to know with these words
lady caroline lamb carved out a literary epitaph
that would last centuries written in reference
to lord byron they sum up everything that still
appeals about the brooding libertine poet george
gordon byron was young charismatic talented at the
age of just 24 he published one of the biggest
hits in the whole of english poetry becoming
famous overnight he was daring traveling the
mediterranean becoming embroiled in secret
societies and joining revolutions he was also
handsome and sexually adventurous in england he
shocked high society with his affairs with married
women while on the continent he found comfort
in the embrace of beautiful young men he was in
short the archetype of a romantic poet a decadent
bohemian aristocrat living a scandalous life
even as he produced some of the greatest poems
that the world has ever known yet there was
more to lord byron than this simple portrait
would suggest beneath the dashing exterior lurked
a soul riven by insecurity plagued with body image
problems and capable of treating his family
in the most appalling way imaginable awful
and wonderful both hero and villain this is the
life of lord byron literature's original bad boy
for nearly all his adult life lord byron was
gripped with an unhealthy fear that he would
one day go mad rather than the affected pose of
a laosh aristocrat this worry was very real the
fear that came from deep within the poet's
heart after all with the parents he had had
it's perhaps a wonder that he had any sanity at
all born gordon george byron on the 22nd january
1788 the future poet was the product of a match
maid somewhere in the ninth circle of hell his
father was a dissolute drunk known as mad jack
who gambled all of his wife's money away before
fleeing abroad while she was pregnant as a result
byron's mother gave birth to him completely alone
in a rented room driven near bankruptcy by the
man she married not that katherine gordon was
exactly a model parent herself moody aggressive
and capable of staggering cruelty the boy's mother
would swing between smothering him with love and
belittling his disability byron had been born with
a withered right leg that caused constant pain
and left him horribly self-conscious but rather
than accept her boy for who he was his mother used
this self-consciousness as a weapon in her darker
mood catherine would zero in on the boy's leg
calling him lame brat or her limping devil while
her casual cruelty would give her son lifelong
hang-ups as an adult he'd wear special boots
designed to hide his disability they also turned
him into someone capable of matching his mother's
put-downs seizing upon her weight the child byron
would scream back that she was as fat as a sow
he began blaming her for his condition chalking
his painful leg up to catherine's insistence on
wearing a corset while pregnant all in all then
it was a miserable life the pair lived shut
off from the world in gentile poverty swinging
between toxic arguments and painful codependency
incredibly this wasn't even the worst
of it in 1791 when byron was only three
mad jek died in france his last act was to
pass all of his debts onto his young son
mad jagbeyer and everybody her dad so deadbeat
was still talking about how crappy he was 230
years later despite his father's feelings though
byron would always consider him a free spirited
adventurer but then given how awful his home
life was perhaps his young brain simply needed
the escapism in 1797 catherine hired a strict
calvinist named mary gray as her son's nurse sadly
gray was one of those christians who used religion
not as a way to reflect and better themselves but
rather as a way to browbeat others violent and
drunken she liked to hit the boy telling him how
sinful and wretched he was far worse than the
physical abuse though was the sexual abuse when
the boy was either nine or ten the age varies in
different versions mary gray began grooming him
culminating in a sustained sexual assault in her
bed it took two years for the boy to block up
the courage to tell anyone but even then there
was no great reckoning gray was dismissed from
the family's employ and simply vanished from the
pages of history yet the hurt she caused didn't
vanish with her in his later life lord byron would
become as we'll soon see capable of breathtaking
acts of cruelty towards his lovers especially when
they were female as bad as his behavior becomes
though just bear in mind this dreadful childhood
growing up in a household filled with both mental
and sexual abuse its remarkable byron didn't
turn out any worse than he actually did
it was the 21st of may 1798 when the family's
fortunes suddenly turned that day byron's great
uncle the guy so villain as he was simply called
the wicked lord died having outlived all his heirs
with no one else to take it byron got his great
uncle's aristocratic title more gratifying though
was the second part of his inheritance newstead
abbey a gossip pile badly in need of repair
newstead was the archetypal great country home
young byron fell in love with the place enchanted
by its vast corridors and crumbling walls sure he
had to rent a doubt to a 23 year old baron to pay
off the family's debt but it was still a step up
there were other positive changes happening around
this time too shortly after inheriting newstead
byron met his cousin margaret parker for the first
time beautiful and enchanting she knocked young
byron off his feet it was thanks to this meeting
that the boy sat down and wrote his first piece
of poetry but these twin beams of sunshine were
just a quick respite from the endless black skies
of byron's early life in 1801 the boy was sent to
study at harrow an elite boarding school that was
also a hotbed of bullying the other boy seized on
byron's disability torturing him over his withered
leg and his weight yup his weight as he got older
byron had fleshed out but rather than accept this
the accumulating fat instilled in him an eating
disorder he began eating starvation amounts of
food fighting off his hunger with tobacco until
his death he'd yo-yo in weight between freakishly
thin and noticeably obese nor was food the only
hangout that byron was developing some biographers
have suggested that byram was seduced around this
time by the baron renting newstead an experience
that seems to have left him angry and confused yet
if byron was messed up after his first homosexual
encounter the feeling wouldn't last by the time
he entered cambridge in 1805 byron was already
aware that he had romantic feelings for both
men and women it was at university that he met his
first love a choir boy two years his junior called
john edelston according to byron he loved the boy
with a violent though pure love and passion with
many scholars taking the pure part to mean his
attraction was unrequited certainly this would fit
the later pattern in the poet's life of falling
for beautiful straight boys that he couldn't have
this wasn't like lusting after a straight friend
today homosexuality in early 19th century england
wasn't just illegal but it was punishable by death
when byron wrote love poetry about edelston he was
forced to invent a female name to hide the truth
still it wouldn't be love poetry whether directed
at men or at women that would make byron's name
but a literary cat fight come 1806 baron had run
out of cash abandoning cambridge for london he
borrowed money from his estranged half-sister
augusta to make ends meet while there he began
compiling his early poems finally publishing
them in 1807 as hours of idleness sadly a better
title might have been great big piles of poo the
press were merciless with the 21 year old's
verse the edinburgh review gleefully took a
hatchet to the book portraying bayern and some
talentless hack who didn't know his villanelle
from his ass it was a nightmare review the sort of
write-up that would put most off writing for life
instead the review wound up being byron's making
rather than abandon poetry the poet went on the
attack over the winter of 1808 to 1809 byron
composed what was basically a diss track so
epic it makes ice cubes no vaseline look like
something by vanilla ice known as english bards
and scotch reviewers the poem attacked not just
the edinburgh review but also pretty much every
major poet in england it was poisonous angry
impertinent it was also brilliant suddenly
lord byron could no longer be dismissed to some
rich idiot the snarling cynical genius of infamy
had arrived now just before we continue with
today's video let me tell you about our fantastic
sponsor squarespace two simple things maybe you've
got an idea for a website or a business or a
youtube channel or a podcast something like that
knocking around in your mind well two the only
way to find out whether that's worth doing is to
get it out into the world and that can be daunting
because it's always scary to go and pursue new
things but not knowing how to set up a website
is no excuse there are no excuses available with
squarespace squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website for whatever you want to do
sell something online yes set up a store with
squarespace you want to do a podcast to start a
youtube channel well i mean you'll do the youtube
channel on youtube but you'll want a website to
complement it and if you've got a podcast well yes
put it on squarespace it all starts on squarespace
with a beautiful template that you can customize
to your heart's content or you can start from
scratch or just move over from an existing domain
making everything super easy to manage and
once you've gone through the customization
process there's no updates there's no
patches there's no technical nonsense
to deal with and squarespace also handles all
that websitey stuff podcasts like i said but
also mailiness social integrations member areas
and so much more head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain and back to today's video
the summer of 1809 saw byron and his friend
john hop house depart england for a grand
tour around the mediterranean in itself this
wasn't unusual the grand tour was simply part
of a wealthy englishman's upbringing in this
era what was unusual though was byron's main
motivation from his letters at the time it's
clear that he mostly wanted a guilt-free way to
seduce a metric heck ton of boys across greece
and albania the young lord fell in and out of
love with countless dashing young men reveling in
how open the mediterranean societies were about
homosexuality in england he wrote with evident
delight the vices in fashion are whoring and
drinking in turkey sodomy and smoking but while
this turkish style was perfect for an attractive
young bisexual guy byron wasn't just thinking
with his dick he could also see around him the
greeks and albanians chafing under the rule of
the decaying ottoman empire their desire for
liberation preyed on his mind and that
in case you somehow missed it is what we
call foreshadowing still oppressed greeks or no
oppressed greeks byron's thoughts at this time
were mostly occupied with his writing the critical
success of english bards had triggered a creative
hot streak as he and hobhouse traveled to places
like malta portugal and spain that creative energy
began to get focused on a big project one
that would apply byron's developing cynical
style to places that it visited child harold's
pilgrimage was a work that would become a pillar
of european romanticism following a world-weary
narrator on his mediterranean travels it was
moody contemplative decadent and utterly ahead
of its time in fact it was so cutting edge that
byron initially refused to publish it thinking
it would cause a scandal it was only thanks to
tragedy that the perm ever saw the light of day
in 1811 byron returned to england to be informed
that his mother was gravely ill although he
raced from london to newstead he was too late
by the time he arrived catherine gordon was dead
despite their difficult relationship his mother's
death nearly broke byron at first he went into
isolation when that didn't help his mood he went
on a violent spree of seduction forcing himself
on the abbey serving girls desperate to pull
himself back from the brink his friends pushed
him into working on child harold the purr grumbled
then agreed then threw himself into the writing
it was a decision that would change everything
the release of child harald's first two kantos in
march 1812 was perhaps the biggest literary event
of the regency era remember when gangnam star
took over the entire planet back in 2012 with
a speed that would never seen before well that
was child harold two centuries earlier albeit
with less funky dancing the prince run sold out
in three days as barron himself later said i awoke
one morning and found myself famous what followed
was an era of byron mania suddenly every club in
london wanted him as a member society hostesses
were begging him to entertain at their parties
it helped that the poem's narrator was clearly
modeled on byron rather than just another writer
those who invited him were getting something
far more interesting a character and byron
was nothing if not a character with his studied
good looks quick tongue and hint of the devil
byron was for the regency what oscar wilde would
be for the late victorian era after the long
pious slog of george the third's reign britain
was changing in byron had finally found a poet
who embodied that change he is really the
only topic almost of every conversation the
duchess of devonshire wrote the men jealous
of him the women of each other indeed society
women were mad for byron they wrote him by
the hundreds begging for a lock of his hair
but they were too late by the spring of
1812 byron only had eyes for one person
lady carolyn lamb unfortunately this new obsession
would wind up a disaster for both of them
in later life byron would recall the years 1812
to 1815 as his reign when he was in his prime
and adored across london but you could just
as easily call them the years of dangerous
relationships in quick succession byron was to
get involved with three women one it destroy
another he'd be destroyed by and the third would
be an exercise in mutual destruction it was into
this latter category that lady caron and lamb fell
slender androgynous and unable to give the tiniest
crap what society thought of her lamb should have
been the perfect match for byron for a few months
she was the two had a wild and kinky affair
with bayern encouraging her to cross-dress and
engaging in scandalous love-making with him it was
lamb who famously wrote the byron was mad bad and
dangerous to know yet in reality those words
were far better suited to her by the fall of
1812 byron becomes so freaked out by lam's
erratic behavior that he broke off their
affair by a letter the next time they bumped into
each other at a ball lamb smashed a glass and
started cutting her arms in front of him a scene
that destroyed her social standing still for all
byron may have damaged her catherine lamb would at
least have her revenge the same can't be said for
the poet's next love annabelle milbank was lamb's
cousin a down-to-earth mathematician who was a far
cry from wild child caroline she and byron struck
up her friendly correspondence at first with
few romantic overtures as lamb snidely noted byron
would never be able to pull with a woman who went
to church punctually understood statistics and
had a bad figure but at some point in 1813 things
changed byron wrote to anabella suggesting
marriage for reasons that are still unknown
one theory is that he wanted a wife to deflect
suspicion about his ongoing gay affairs another is
well we'll come to that in a minute for now we'll
note that annabella turned byron down only to have
a change of heart in 1814 and tell him he could
ask again byron didn't hesitate the pair wed in
january 1815 and from the get-go it was clear that
this was a more cursed match than even that of
mad jack and katherine gordon byron seemed to find
alabella loathsome in some undefined way the night
they married he was found wandering about with a
loaded pistol muttering about blowing his brains
out he taunted his new wife with hints of gay love
affairs openly seduced an actress while anabella
was pregnant with his child but the biggest issue
of all was also byron's third great love of this
period augusta the daughter of mad jack augusta
was byron's half-sister a married respectable ish
woman we briefly introduced loaning him money two
chapters back when they reconnected in 1813 though
the pair no longer wanted to be just siblings they
wanted to be lovers now it's important to point
out that no definitive proof exists of byron in
augusta's incestual relationship that being said
there are so many red flags that take it together
they become a giant semaphore signal screaming
warning this is gross this is the other theory
behind byron's ill-advised marriage that he needed
to throw people off the center of his affair
with his half-sister but if that's the case it
failed mainly because byron himself kept dropping
hints to annabella about it by this time their
marriage was beyond repair byron was being cruel
to his heavily pregnant wife smashing bottles and
firing pistols to keep her from getting to sleep
at night things finally culminated in december
of 1815. on the 10th annabella gave birth to
their daughter ada byron better known to history
as the pioneering programmer ada lovelace no way
how did i feel like i must know that that's crazy
i feel like i did know that damn i
mean i must have made a video about it
that's crazy two days later while she was still
recovering byron allegedly entered the room
and sodomized her we say allegedly because
as with much of lord byron's private life
it's unknown what was really true and what
were just rumors concocted by his enemies
either way annabella fled with their daughter
just a month later not long after rumors began
doing the rounds of domestic violence and abuse
within their marriage yet it was the other rumors
that would annihilate byron's reputation aware
the winds were shifting against the poet carolyn
lam began spreading her own stories about byron
of incest of homosexual lovers in no time at all
these tales would turn byron from the darling of
english society into a desperate wounded exile
back when byron was on his grand tour a
proto-police force known as the bow street
runners had raided london's white swan pub the
target had been the gay man who gathered there in
the trials that followed six were sentenced to the
stocks and another two were hanged their official
crime was sodomy and it triggered a crackdown
so violent that not even someone as wealthy
as byron could escape it when the accusations of
incest homosexuality and sodomy broke against him
byron transformed overnight into a walking target
his friends feared he'd be lynched in the streets
so the poet did the only thing he could he ran
on april 25 1816 lord byron boarded a ship for
the european mainland although he traveled in
style not just taking his personal physician john
polidori but also a pet monkey and peacock there
was no getting over the sadness of the occasion
the departure of the boat from dover marked the
last time byron would ever see his home country
from a literary perspective though this exile
was the best thing that could have ever happened
shunned by society byron now began working harder
than ever writing with an anger that pushed his
poems to new heights it would be while on
this creative streak that he made his most
important artistic friendship back in england
one of byron's many lovers had been 18 year old
claire claremont when she heard that he was going
to spend part of his exile in geneva she pushed
her stepsister mary wollstonecraft godwin and
mary's fiancee to travel there with her and so it
was that the future mary shelly and her lover the
struggling romantic poet percy by she shelley came
to be in switzerland at the perfect time to meet
lord byron we say perfect because the friendship
the three struck up transformed literary history
it was byron's suggestion that they all tell
ghost stories while reigned in one night and
that led to mary shelley write in frankenstein as
well as polidori creating the modern vampire novel
percy shelly and byron meanwhile inspired one
another both saw a great outpouring of work
during their time together work that would
redefine english poetry sadly things were nowhere
near so positive for claire claremont that summer
in geneva byron seduced her knocked her up and
then got bored of her and encouraged her to
return to england that claire gave birth to their
daughter clara allegra byron it was the beginning
of a nightmare byron's treatment of claire and
allegra remains one of the biggest black marks
against him a mixture of cruelty and callous
indifference that still stomach churning to
hear first he sent for allegra telling claire
that he could provide a better life for her
only to quickly get bored of the child and pass
her off onto friends he then blocked claire from
having any contact with her refusing to reply to
her pitiful letters begging for news he started
referring to allegra as that brat and claiming she
wasn't his before finally dumping her in convent
she died there at the age of five unloved and
only visited by percy shelley on her deathbed she
begged to see her father and the poet never came
at the same time as his daughter was enduring her
short and miserable childhood byron was settling
into a new life in italy and beginning work on his
masterpiece don juan is a satirical epic drenched
in sex and scandal both far richer and far darker
than anything byron had yet attempted partially
a sustained send-up of multiple nations it was
both an enormous success back in england and
also so scandalous that his publisher refused
to put his name on it but while don juan would go
down in history as his most lasting achievement
it wasn't a literature that byron would dedicate
what remained of his life but to revolution
by 1820 byron was getting restless while writing
epic poetry in an ancient city whilst also having
an affair with a beautiful italian countess would
probably be enough excitement for most of us byron
felt something lacking he thought about traveling
to south america then still fighting its wars
of independence or maybe returning to england to
lead a revolution in sure byron was searching for
something more than just art for some meaningful
romantic cause to dedicate his life to fortunately
1820s europe was awash with romantic causes that
year the secret carbonari societies of italy began
a series of uprisings against austrian rule that
countess byron was seeing countess teresa guccioli
well her brother was a member of the carbonari
through him byron joined italy's fight for
freedom and unification something he called
a grand object the very poetry of politics
sadly the uprisings were quickly beaten back
byron and the countess's family fled romantic
dreams of revolution unfulfilled yet italian
unification wasn't the only great cause going
in early 1821 greece exploded in revolt
against his ottoman occupiers in no time at
all societies sympathetic to the greek cause were
flourishing across europe in england the london
greek committee sprang up determined to help one
of its members happened to be byron's old friend
john hobhouse the guide accompanied byron on his
grand tour all to aware of his pal's fondness for
greece hobau suggested they sound the poet out
about helping maybe hobhouse was expecting money
maybe just support for their cause what he
got was a military commander when he heard
the proposal byron declared he'd sail for greece
immediately using ten thousand pounds of his own
money he paid to improve the greek navy and fund
a small mercenary force that would operate under
his command on the vayner side he also paid
for an absurd greek costume to wear and had
himself painted in it looking heroic but while
byram was certainly a poser he was also actually
a guy who did stuff in august 1823 he set sail
for the heart of the war yet despite his dreams
he'd never see action incapable of knowing he was
now in the last few months of his life byron spent
the rest of the summer and all of autumn on the
island of catalonia making contacts for the coming
campaign he also fell in love with the last time
with a straight greek chap called lucas challenger
sanos who politely refused the older man's amorous
advances it was only in early 1824 that byron
actually arrived in miss alongi to join the forces
of prince alexander mavrocordatos at first it
seemed to be the beginning of something big byron
as the wealthy foreign celebrity who joined their
cause got a hugely enthusiastic reception from
the greeks the rest of january was spent making
military plans for when the bad weather finally
let up in the end though byron would never see any
of these plans through in a poetic world we'd now
tell you that byron died in battle enjoying the
hero's death that he so clearly craved but that's
not the world we live in in this world byron's
health nosedive that spring following a convulsion
although he tried to relax and recover things only
got worse until on the rainy morning of april the
10th 1824 the poet was stricken with fever his
physicians tried draining his blood a cure that
made things worse before long byron was delirious
slipping in and out of dreams in which he was
spit about augusta finally on april the 19th he
was heard to mutter i want to sleep now then with
those words he died the news of byron's passing
age just 36 spread quickly across greece where
it became a rallying cry for battle it took far
longer to reach his homeland people in london only
heard the news about a month later at which time
the entire city plunged into shock byron might
have been a scandalous even despised figure but
he was also a mega star one of those people you
can't imagine ever dying until they actually do
when his body was returned from greece against his
wishes crowds lined the street to pay their last
respects to say goodbye to the poet who defined
an entire era with 200 years of hindsight we can
now see that byron's legacy was even longer
lasting than anyone could have imagined today
he's likely the best-known english poet after
shakespeare his influence visible across
multiple generations characters like heathcliff
public icons like oscar wilde even rock stars
all owe a debt of gratitude to byron's work and
life of course nowadays we're more likely to be
turned off by byron's dark side by his treatment
of loved ones and his many casual cruelties even
so there's no denying that he remains a towering
figure a pioneer not just in literature but in
revolutionary politics lgbt history and more
the man may have died but the romantic byronic
myth lives on so i really hope you found
this video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching